it's that time of year again when
Americans eagerly await the arrival of
Girl Scout cookies a tradition that has
endured for over a century well once
baked at home the cookies are now
factory made with one common but
controversial ingredient palm oil mainly
produced in Southeast Asia palm oil has
made its way into at least half of all
packaged Goods in the average
supermarket and even used in biodiesel
but how it is made is provoking both
ethical and environmental concerns now
one girl scout troop is taking a
surprising action stepping away from the
annual fundraiser that defines their
organization
in my honor I will try in the basement
of this Jersey City nursing home girl
scout troop 12026 is in community
service mode
making cards for residents while
brainstorming alternatives to the big
fundraiser they ditched three years ago
The Perennial Girl Scout cookie sale who
here misses selling cookies I miss
selling them but it's for a good cause
troop leader Gina vertibello sold
cookies with her Scouts for a decade
until 2021 when a story in her local
newspaper changed everything there was
an article on Olivia Chaffin she's a
girl scout in Tennessee she has a
petition out to get rid of the palm oil
and cookies I thought to myself let me
look more into it before I bring it to
the girls because I don't want to you
know I don't know what truth
let me do my research that research led
to a 2020 Associated Press investigation
of the 106 billion dollar palm oil
industry in Industry the AP linked to
severe tropical deforestation and
exploitative child labor practices you
see whole families out there harvesting
the palm oil because they have to reach
certain quotas every day and so a lot of
times kids won't be in school they'll be
out helping their parents reach those
quotas Ginger Cassidy has been on the
ground with the rainforest Action
Network a non-profit she leads committed
to protecting the environment how old
are these children oh we've seen kids
out there the age of six about the same
age American girls can take the girl
scout oath and contribute to the annual
sale of 800 million dollars worth of
cookies
treats that likely contain unsustainable
palm oil the ingredient label says as
much that certification seal verifies
that palm oil produced through ethical
standards is actually mixed with oils
that may not be and the industry reports
only a fifth of global palm oil Meats
the sustainability standard I said
listen I need you to make the decision
if you think it's best not to sell then
we won't sell but if we don't sell you
might not sell again so she came to you
with this problem
and then what happened
then we all voted and we all we all
voted no yeah it was unanimous yeah
yeah I think
I think we all knew that it was for the
greater good that we all stopped Girl
Scouts Leslie Lewis Iris verdebello and
Trixie Goodall along with their 11 other
troop members wrote the Girl Scouts of
America demanding an ingredient change
their response a form letter via email
how do you take the response
it makes me sad yeah like something that
we've we've worked so hard for
which is the Girl Scouts just
for them to ignore it yeah like they
don't care you feel ignored and
disappointed
and people who were supposed to like
we're supposed to make the world a
better place but we're not the Girl
Scouts of America says it's trying to
find an alternative to palm oil but
currently there's nothing available on
the market the organization declined our
request for an interview releasing this
statement saying in part child labor has
no place in the production of Girl Scout
cookies if certain suppliers are not
following best practices we expect the
Roundtable unsustainable palm oil of
which the Girl Scouts is an affiliate
member to take action quickly
the rspo is one of the trade
organizations in charge of Industry
certification standards right now only
about two percent of globally traded
palm oil is under the rspo label just
two percent exactly that group also
declined our interview requests but said
in an email we applaud Girl Scouts
troops for drawing attention to some of
the issues associated with unsustainable
palm oil production as for claims of
child labor the rspo didn't deny the
problem but said while it can impose
appropriate sanctions it's not a
policing organization
it added that it's setting the strictest
certification standards currently
applicable to the palm oil industry
Unfortunately they can't be trusted
because we've still been able to find
connections with rspo certified uh palm
oil that's still connected to Tropical
deforestation and egregious labor
practices so it's really up to all of us
including the Girl Scouts to apply
pressure to the rspo and the companies
that are supplying this palm oil that is
still not sustainably sourced
bigger eyes are watching too the United
Nations for one through its
International labor organization I do
think it is important to understand that
in Global Supply chains that you have a
rather complex network of suppliers
Kevin Cassidy leads the U.S division
there's always clever ways that people
find around this but I think what's
really quite important is that if the
legislation is in place if the
enforcement is in place and the access
to justice is in place then those issues
can be addressed more firmly I
that troop of Jersey Girls what's
husking the bitter
out they're sweet we still like Girl
Scouts not that we don't like Girl
Scouts we do we like you know our
meetings and doing the things that we do
like the service projects but you know
the cookies right now there's just
either on hold or whenever there are
hundreds of products with palm oil in it
the Girl Scouts
cookie sale is a drop in the bucket why
are you so focused on that because if we
change then it proves that the other
companies can change too yeah yeah and
plus we're Girl Scouts and we want to
make the world a better place and use
resources wisely so the fact that we
aren't using our resources wisely is
kind of like then what's the whole point
of this
well troop 120 26 has been running
service projects off of donations from
their Community parents have started to
chip in and even their troop leader Gina
she's put up money to keep their troop
running